hello everybody and welcome back to the
epic conclusion of limbo all right we
are at the end as people have told me so
let's see how the story unfolds I'm very
very curious to see what happens here I
can't jump anymore
I cannot jump anymore oh that girl yeah
Chiz oh I can't move it
oh you gotta be kidding me that was it
that was the end
Wow I should have just walked a few
steps forward I that was my mistake guys
I really did not think that through but
anyway so this is gonna be like a micro
micro video but anyway that was a really
really amazing game honest-to-goodness
that was one of the best indie games I
played in a while I love the puzzle
platformer style game but it was just
such an interesting world that that's
what made it so unique it was just a
totally new take on the platformer
stopping the same in the same way that
portal did but this one did it like
completely silent in in black and white
it just had that feel and this always
has to add that emotion to it and that's
what's really great again so that was
incredible and I although you know maybe
it's good happy ending little little
chunk but that's okay but I really do
appreciate everyone for
all the work to make this game it is
that's really incredible
yep back at the end
wow that was some special guys thank you
for everyone who recommended that sorry
that movie was so short but that's the
way it goes sometimes I make a mistake
but anyway thank you all so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye